After Apollo 13’s near disaster, the fate
of the lunar program was back on rocky ground.
Apollo 14 was scheduled to launch before the
end of the year and it would provide the most
extensive scientific exploration yet,
but if it was ever going to take off,
investigators needed to determine what exactly went wrong on Apollo 13.
And NASA had to make sure that it wouldn’t happen again.
The investigation found that the
near-disaster was a combination of
human and design error.
The source of the explosion was an oxygen
tank inside the Service Module.
Before it made it onto Apollo 13, the tank
went through a series of problems.
In 1968, it was scheduled to fly on Apollo
but was accidentally dropped on the ground before the mission.
After it passed a series of tests, it was
cleared to fly on Apollo 13.
But then, in 1970, during pre-flight testing,
the tank wasn’t emptying as it should.
So, to gasify the liquid oxygen, technicians
turned on the tank’s heater using 65 volts
which should have been fine since the spacecraft
components were all modified
to handle increased power in 1965.
But unfortunately, the thermostatic switch
within the oxygen tank
was still geared for just 28 volts.
It was later found that the excess power caused
the switch to weld shut, and the temperature
inside the tank rose to over 500 degrees Celsius
and damaged insulation on the wires inside
the tank, leaving a high risk for a short
circuit.
From the outside, though, everything appeared
to be... good enough to fly.
So on April 11, 1970 Apollo 13 essentially
lifted off with a time bomb inside the service module.
After the near disaster,
NASA had to make major structural changes
to the Command-Service Module and the Lunar
Module.
Improvements were also made to the astronauts
airtight spacesuits
and the lunar surface experiment equipment.
Apollo 14 would be the first crewed mission
to put these upgrades to the test.
NASA selected Astronaut Alan Shepard as the
mission’s commander.
Almost ten years prior, Shepard became the
first American in space during Project Mercury.
Apollo 14 would mark his triumphant return
after a rare disease
kept him grounded for many years.
Joining Shepard, were rookies Edgar Mitchell
and Stuart Roosa.
About nine months after Apollo 13, NASA was
headed back to the moon.
Apollo 14 was en route to the Fra Mauro formation
- a ridged region that was believed to be
made up of an ejecta blanket from a collision
between a huge mass and the Moon.
This made it an ideal landing location for
science.
But getting there wasn’t as smooth as NASA
hoped.
Once in lunar orbit, it took six attempts before the crew could dock the Command and Lunar Modules.
And then during the descent to the Moon, the
lunar module signaled an abort.
Mission control and the astronauts worked
through the problems though, and the crew eventually
pulled off a high precision landing within
target range.
On the surface, Shepard and Mitchell attempted
a trek to the rim of the Cone Crater, collecting
lunar rocks in their space wagon along the
way.
They also measured the strength of the Moon’s
magnetic field, collected samples of the solar
wind and studied the properties of lunar soil.
Additional experiments were deployed that
enabled scientists to monitor activity from Earth.
Some of these experiments would go on to detect
lunar "moonquakes", providing information
about the internal structure of the Moon.
And others would study the lunar ionosphere
and measure the precise distance
between Earth and the Moon.
Back on the CSM, Roosa conducted orbital science
activities that measured regional variations
in the Moon's gravitational acceleration and
the scattering of radar waves from the lunar surface.
Apollo 14 packed in more science than any
mission before it,
pushing the astronauts to new extremes.
They collected over 40 kilograms of rocks
and soil from the lunar surface including
this one nicknamed "Big Bertha."
And Shepard, the oldest man to get to the
moon, set a new distance-traveled record on
the lunar surface equivalent to about 55 laps
in an Olympic-sized pool.
But aside from the extensive experiments and
massive terrain covered, Apollo 14 is best
remembered for this moment when Alan Shepard
broke out a modified six iron and hit two
golf balls into the cosmic distance.
The astronauts then headed back to the CSM
to begin their return to Earth.
Apollo 14 has a longstanding legacy linked
to discovery.
The lunar samples returned have been studied
for decades, helping scientists better estimate
the age and physical nature of the moon.
Photos from the mission verified the role
of volcanism in the formation and modification
of lunar highlands and documented deep-space
phenomena known as Zodiacal light and Gegenschein.
Seeds that were aboard the mission were planted
around the world and have since grown into
living monuments of the third trip to the
Moon.
Apollo 14 also validated the changes NASA
made after the Apollo 13 disaster and demonstrated
that spaceflight challenges are solvable.
The next missions would build off this
momentum, taking exploration capabilities
even further with the introduction of a new
way for astronauts to explore the lunar surface.
If you want to learn more Apollo 13 and how NASA got the astronauts home safely,
check out this video.
And make sure to subscribe to Seeker for all things science.
Thanks for watching!